well you're looking City superheroes in
the divergent franchise but you are
gonna see a lot of action I mean it's
larger than life and that means that the
cast has to pull off some crazy wild
stunts in the new installment Allegiant
and only Michelle Turner went behind the
scenes to see just how they did it ready
and three two one go
how many of your own stunts are you
doing here oh we're just doing some wire
work on to the shooting range to get
ready for this movie so yeah it's good
that's pretty cool yep there are
explosions careening down cliffs I said
one against two entanglements boom but
today it's a wall I giant wall that
would make Donald Trump jealous it's
like 700 feet and it's really it's so
actually it's 80 feet high tough enough
we did this bit with che had to be kind
of facing down I was holding onto Theo's
shoulder like like it was the last thing
my whole costume got torn up yesterday
this is a new one so by the end today
it'll get totally torn up you had to run
in those yeah these are my shoes these
are my action shoes they spent six
months shooting outside of Atlanta for
Maggie Q that meant travel time for
fiancee Dylan McDermott I did drag him
to visit me hahahaha in the heat before
guys I honey I gotta go to live here
speaking of hot well that would
certainly describe the careers of this
cast pretty much unknown only three
years ago I feel it more as people say
it hey you're miles teller rest before
is like did you do we go to high school
together hey miles it's only the
beginning for you trust me man
you